I have been experiencing head and foot syndrome. This is a common syndrome as a
chemo side effect where chemo damages your peripheral nerves and so
chemo is a toxin and it could you know why do people have peripheral nerve
damage with chemo more than central nerve damage with chemo well you can have
central nerve damage as well with chemo but the reason why you have an
increased possibility of peripheral nerve damage with chemo is that as we age
our our circulation is not as good to even even with young people our
circulation is not as good to the peripheral areas of our hands and our feet as it
is to our core of our body so chemo a toxin can settle in those areas and can
cause all sorts of damage that's why it's a syndrome because it could be
a collection of symptoms so in you it looks like it's causing blisters on your
feet would it be good to continue foot baths or should I hold off on those and
tell the blisters are resolved you don't you do want to be careful with foot baths if
you have an open wound if it's a blister and it's not an open wound could you
still do a foot bath technically yes if you find that it causes irritation when
you do that to the area that's blister then I'd say back off but if you're like
no that doesn't make it worse than I'd say it would be better to continue to do
them because you the way the foot bath can help pull those toxins out of your
body make sure you're supporting your liver make sure you're doing like hot packs
over your liver make sure you're doing coffee animals that's gonna be the best
thing to decrease head and foot syndrome with coffee animal with the chemotherapy
really supporting liver detox pathways supporting flow supporting lymphatic flow
because that's really the issue remember you don't have you know a heart that's
pumping you know fluid through your limb vessels you're completely dependent upon
the action of your muscles and gravity so we do is doing some lymphatic exercises
doing some you know just getting some better lymphatic flow and I have a
bunch of videos on that and I think some blog posts on that too is going to be
your best thing to do to help move those toxins out of the body through the liver
but then you have to be supporting your liver pathways and making sure
that they're all the downstream pathways from there your gallbladder and your
and your gut is open and you're having good bowel movements and all that